I mean he was left right and deep his
face and she was like I mean that was
such a great match even though obviously
it didn't last very long but yeah I mean
he he took a few on the chin real hard
to get in there and for stupid that's
got to drive him [ __ ] crazy he has
been tweeting a lot why wouldn't he get
a straight rematch straight away I mean
there's even supposedly talk on McGregor
getting a rematch when he got pretty
much handled everywhere I don't think
this real talk of McGregor getting a
rematch I think the real smart money is
on Tony Ferguson fighting khabib next I
think
Dane has been saying that I i 100%
believe that Tony Ferguson desert I
don't think Tony Ferguson should have
ever been stripped I think he should
still be the interim champion I mean the
guy fell while he was doing press and
tore his knee apart
six months later comes back and destroys
Anthony Pettis and a spectacular
performance fight Oh
Pettis was great - [ __ ] yeah he was
Tony's just Tony's just a warrior I mean
he's cardio never runs out
he throws weird stuff with everything
you can throw you don't know parently
got upset that we called him a weirdo
like I guess he's sensitive apparently
got upset I said he was a brilliant
weirdo like when he was on his way to
the cage but I meant that a hundred
entry wears ankle weights at the
weigh-ins yeah like I don't even know
what I mean he uses a Wing Chun dummy he
sets up his all's camp like his training
equipment he sets it up himself he puts
the mats down he builds his own like
heavy bag hangers he puts he puts up
like chin-up bars all that [ __ ] does it
himself he's like it's unfamiliar to the
average training regimen yes I'm in
elementary I'm a huge fan of that guy I
am I also think that he is the toughest
test for khabib because of his cardio
and because of his versatility because
he could fight really well off his back
I mean he submitted Kevin Lee off his
back to win the title yeah he's got a
fantastic Darce choke and his ability to
hold guys in his guard and recover if he
gets clipped I mean he's he's the most
dangerous guy at lightweight for khabib
I think in my opinion yeah he just never
gets [ __ ] tired it doesn't even make
sense
yeah and Eddie you know Eddie trains him
he's one of Eddie's just
Eddie says he's never seen anything like
he said this guy work out six hours a
day full clip everybody else is
exhausted he keeps going there doing
sprints up the hill Tony laps everybody
and keeps going his cardio is off the
chart he I wonder if that's a Mexican
thing too I think there's a lot of
Mexicans that have amazing cardio every
lion's right I don't know what it is man
I mean if it's a running thing for sure
but I mean if you go back to like a maca
I think I mean Gilbert Melendez said
that once - that it's a Mexican thing
this cardio because Gilbert's always
been known for his crazy cardio I really
wonder if there's like certain
ethnicities that have an advantage or at
least a better starting point and then
it's all hard work from there yeah the
most maybe there's some genetic thing
you can prove from the way the blood
holds off Diego Sanchez he's another one
insane cardio yeah I mean I don't know I
mean it's a it's a it's a fun thing to
think about I mean you go like you go
back to boxing in particular I mean how
many great boxers had fantastic cardio
from Mexico
you know Chavez in particular Julio
Cesar Chavez which is where guys down
the volume of his punching you just
never stopped just constantly on you
constantly moving forward bobbing and
weaving and throwing shots and sometimes
as an athlete like if you're a boxer
you'd have to even if you didn't have
that you'd have to dig deep and pretend
you had that you know what I mean that
starts wearing another guy like this
guys never pressure and stop you know
like I had a I had a situation once I
was super winded I was really tired you
know in a heat surfing as a guy in
Tahiti and this this he ended up sort of
being like a world title heat for me and
I was losing with like two minutes ago
and I ended up in this paddle battle
against a guy and he's good paddler and
pretty fit guy
and we're like head-to-head and what
happens week whoever gets back out first
deemed by the judges gets priority over
the next wave they can have whatever the
way they want with two minutes three
minutes left and a heat surfing there's
that's not a lot of time to get a wave
if if the wave comes you got to be the
guy it has priority for it and we're
paddling and I could feel him just for
half a second kind of lit up on his
paddle like okay I'm getting ahead on
this guy and as soon as you did I paddle
harder and I was like I you know to show
him like I got more and he gave up and I
got it and then I got then I needed like
a pot you know we score out of 10 points
and I needed like a nine I got like a
nine point four with thirty seconds ago
or something it was just but it was I
didn't have that in me like physically I
was like I want to quit too you know but
I was like I got a poker face this guy
make it think I got more you know and I
I really didn't it was just that choice
like I don't care I'm gonna get out
there with the lungs burning and I'll
feel bad for thirty seconds whatever
yeah you know but sometimes you I would
imagine boxers prep type or MMA guys for
sure sometimes you can't Bluff that but
right sometimes you can't Bluff it but
yeah for sure it does come up where
there's an edge one way or the other
that's a big